calls for the so called people's votes
on the final brexit deal aren't growing
lighter and leading that charges open
Britain champion Lord Adonis who joins
me in the studio lovely to see you again
morning the yin and yang of British
politics perhaps bill cash in yourself
what did you make of what you heard from
him there but what's interesting about
what bill cash said is that his totally
unreconciled be opposed to what to
resume has set out on Friday from
checkers so already the checkers
agreement is breaking down because what
you're finding is a good half maybe two
thirds of the Conservative Party is
strongly opposed including at least a
third of the cabinet we know what Boris
Johnson described it as in the papers
today so they're already starting up
before any negotiations have taken place
with Brussels at all they're starting
out with a charge of this being a
sellout because it will still involve
some measure of agreement with European
Union over trading goods some role for
the European Court of Justice and so on
now people like me we look at this in
horror and say look what we need is the
national economic interest people's jobs
livelihoods incomes are at stake what
the government has agreed on Friday is
that 80 percent of our trade with you
have 80 percent which is in services or
our financial services our business
services our media all of the she's huge
services require they're not going to be
covered at all we've already agreed in
advance that we're not going to have a
deal on those only on goods because the
Prime Minister doesn't actually want to
have customs controls because of the
issue to do with Ireland so what you've
now got is two irreconcilable positions
you've got a large proportion of people
I think it's a majority who look at this
an increase in horror they asked the
question two years ago did you vote to
be poorer and that's why the demand for
people's vote is growing but she's also
losing control of her party on the other
side but just on that and you didn't
really need to work too hard to read
between the lines with Bill cashes as
you said there but doesn't he have a
point that actually people who voted for
Breck's are going to be aware in the
majority did not vote for a situation
where we did not have sole control of
our borders where we didn't have sole
control of our laws where we didn't have
sole control of our trade what the truth
is no one knew what they were voting for
to is good cuz there was no leave
proposition the only question on the
ballot paper was do you wish to leave
the European Union or to remain leaving
has 101 different variants - you know
there's Norway which is
in the European Union but is incredibly
close in terms of the whole way its
economy is integrated but then you also
have of course a situation where you
could have no relationship of the
European Union all together and that's
what bill cash wants now the truth is no
one new said the right thing to do is
now for the Prime Minister on the basis
of checkers to see what she can
negotiate with with our European
partners and then the British people
should have a look at that they should
ask the question is this gonna make you
poorer is it going to sacrifice our
influence in the world are we going to
be worse off with the alternative being
staying in and the longer this fast goes
on because we've now had two years of it
I think the clear it's becoming to the
British people that the right course is
not to sacrifice our jobs our
international influence we live in a
dangerous world at the moment stepping
in ourselves in Europe but to stay in
through a democratic process we're the
people's but it seems to be the
get-out-of-jail-free card used by
yourself and others who do not like the
result of the referendum who would wish
to see that result overturned that
j'adore the but the ballot paper didn't
tell us what end situation we'd end up
in actually what the ballot did was give
the Prime Minister the authority to
secure the exit from the European Union
that she thought best and we've got it
now why don't you support him he
wouldn't even know that resume was gonna
be Prime Minister with the referendum
two years camembert's David Cameron and
member he told us all thoughts of the
government's daughter and she's had an
election since then was she lost you
know she hasn't got a majority in the
House of Commons
I've sat through nearly 200 hours of
debates in the House of Lords on the EU
withdraw were bill and each day the
government position changes so the right
thing to do because we're a democracy is
we've let this thing run there was a
narrow referendum result two years ago
she does clearly have the authority to
negotiate on our behalf but when she has
negotiated and we've got the treaty the
right democratic thing is for Parliament
when they look at it and promenade
itself reject it but I think the right
thing is for Parliament to refer it to
the people and that's not just my view
the opinion polls now show a big
majority for a referendum and it's
obviously you know as well as I do that
there will have been people watching
this back at home who will have hold at
the screen when you use the words you
know we live in a democracy
of course we live in a democracy we've
had an election last year which led to a
big swing against the Conservatives
we had a narrow referendum two years ago
in
few weeks time there would have been a
longer interval between now and the last
referendum than between the last two
general elections remember we had
general elections in 2017 and 2015
regular consultation with the people is
what democracy is all about particularly
on massive issues which are changing
over time and the critical thing about
breaks it you know I don't wish the
Prime Minister any ill-will at all is
absolutely right she's seeking to
negotiate on our behalf but she does not
have the unilateral power because we're
not in a dictatorship to agree to
departure terms with Brussels without
consulting Parliament and I think the
right thing to do is for Parliament then
to refer it to the people who all
opinion polls show now overwhelmingly
support having their say before we crash
after the European Union and people
become poorer I mean but don't you think
your party should actually just fess up
be honest about what exactly what their
position is when it comes to all of this
I mean you're speaking to Tony Lloyd a
couple of minutes a few minutes ago I
mean I'm no clearer as to whether or not
a people's vote the prospect of a
people's will has been ruled out or not
I mean would you leave the Labour Party
if the if the leadership made it
absolutely crystal clear that there
would not be a people's vote and under a
Labour guy I'm not leaving the Labour
Party and let's be clear the pro
Europeans are the overwhelming majority
in the labour party the people who want
a people's vote are in the overwhelming
majority both in the parliamentary
Labour Party amongst Labour MPs but also
within the membership at large what the
party membership wants is Jeremy Corbyn
for whom they have great respect they
want him to to follow the right course
for the country and responds to the
great majority in the party and they
happen to be the same thing which is
don't trash working people of Britain by
agreeing to a deal which is going to
make them all poorer let's have a
people's votes let's reject all this and
then we can move on to the big agenda
which is so important for the country
rebuilding the NHS dealing with the
housing crisis better education all of
these things which can't be done while
we're obsessing night and day with
bricks in football result we've got a
bit of light relief thank goodness at
the moment we're capable of talking
tonight you know your waste case speaks
volumes that's the last is the last time
it gets mentioned on this show if I have
anything to do with it and Oh dawn it's
lovely to see thank you joining us